foreign
uh
uh
part of the campaign by the cia against
nicaragua isn't is through paramilitary
units and squads of
somas former soma sista soldiers who are
being trained in honduras
and their campaign is against these
mosquito indians and a lot of hundreds
of mosquitoes have been killed by those
squads and cross-border raids now the
circumstances of this killing are pure
terrorism
recruiting terrorists to go across the
border and blow up and assassinate and
kill
we have to remember that the next time
president reagan or alexander the hague
are making their pious statements about
the threat of international terrorism
and the horrors of international
terrorism the united states is without
any serious competition leading the
world in international terrorism
today and for the past 30 years
the last in our three-part series on
what the intelligence services are doing
with john stockwell former cia official
and editor of covert action information
bulletin lewis wolf
tonight on alternative views
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is our last program in the series
on what the government and private
intelligence organizations are doing
around the world
this is lewis wolfe co-editor of covert
action information bulletin which
specializes in revealing what these
organizations are doing
our other guest is john stockwell
who was with the cia for many years
had a high position in the organization
actually ran their
angolan operation
and quit wrote the book
in search of enemies subsequently a new
novel red sunset
tonight we'll discuss particularly
the cia in latin america
and the total ramification on how this
fits in to the united states foreign
policy and the ramifications overseas
let's have some news
everybody knows there's unemployment
but the cost
to the american people to individuals as
well as the economy and the social
fabric of the nation is staggering
for instance
each one percent increment of
unemployment diminishes the gross
national product by about 68 billion
these are 1980 estimates a lot of
studies now being made by sociologists
and economists so the impact of
of unemployment and this is just one of
the statistics
the direct cost to the federal
government and lost tax revenue and
increased expenditures for each one
percent rise in unemployment is over 25
billion
and of course
when the deficit goes up so the interest
rates and that puts an additional burden
on the economy
but these statistics on unemployment
actually underestimate the problem
because you have to add to the
unemployment which we have right now to
almost 10 percent
the 5.8 million involuntary part-time
workers or they're at a record high to
1.2 million
and also add the record number of
discouraged workers 10.8 million so you
actually get a grand total of unemployed
or partly employed
17.8 million or
16.2 percent now if you also compare
this with a great depression and to
count in the factor of the millions of
people who are in the armed forces are
working for the government in
relationship to defense
take them out of it and put them on
unemployed roles like they were back in
1929 we actually would have an
unemployment great rate much more severe
than of the great depression
it even gets worse when you talk about
individuals they've found now that each
percentage point of increase of
unemployment sustained over five years
provides a 4.1 increase in suicides
4.3 percent increase among men 2.3 among
women in first-time admissions to state
mental hospitals 1.9 percent increase in
deaths from
disease an increase of four percent in
prison admissions 5.7 percent increase
in homicides and of course kids who
don't get jobs during the summer are
more likely to turn to crime to make
ends meet
so everything isn't just the cold hard
well today friends the unemployment rate
rose up almost to 10
people are hurting
some people are not though some people
are not in fact while a lot of people
are hurting for the unemployment and the
poor are getting poorer under
reaganomics the rich are getting richer
forbes magazine advertises itself on
television as a capitalist tool that
will help young executives get the
skills and the information they need to
help them in their climb up the
corporate ladder and every year they
they publish the salaries of the highest
20 corporate executives and the winner
this year folks
was the president of warner's
communication who came in for a cool 27
and a half million dollars a year
they also listed the next person who was
7.5 million a year also a corporate
executive of a communications empire and
then listed the next 20 corporate
executives all of whom made over a
million dollars a year missing for the
first time from the top 20 were
corporation executives from the
automobile the steel or the
manufacturing industries which evidently
aren't doing so well under today's
economy in fact craig you have some
information that small business like the
poor and the unemployed are suffering
the age of reaganomics right and not so
small necessarily i like to call this
little bit of commentary still we got
fun
yes folks it's time once again to ask
how's business
not so good to put it in a nutshell
but if you've been following the annex
of the reagan team you know it's not
their fault
when inflation dips below the
double-digit level it's because
reaganomics is taking hold
but when leading economic indicators
continue to shrivel and die on the vine
then of course it's the business blight
brought on by that old peanut farmer
jimmy carter lingering on
you might say that politicians in
general can display an amazing
flexibility in some matters
particularly when relating to interim
elections
well the lingering effects of peanut
policy this time has led to a virtual
epidemic of bankruptcies
the wall street journal reports a
post-depression high in the percentage
of failing firms
for the first three months of this year
an average of 36 businesses per hour
have gone belly up
an increase from last year of 29
at that pace nearly 75 000 companies
will go bankrupt this year a new
american record
now these aren't just your family-run
shoestring organizations either
bran if airlines for one went down in
flames recently and indications are that
international harvester may soon join
the scrap heap
with revenues last year of over seven
billion dollars
international harvester would be the
largest u s company ever to file
bankruptcy
at least for the time being that is
edward altman the chairman of the mba
program at new york university estimates
that 200 of the biggest 2 000 industrial
concerns now teeter on the brink of
collapse
well inevitably the big losers when a
company folds are the workers
four out of five bankruptcy filings are
for straight liquidation as in that's
all she wrote
in the trucking industry for example 144
companies have gone under since mid 1980
at the cost of over 28 000 jobs
but that's not the worst of it
consider the plight of hundreds of west
virginia coal miners
who are stuck with unpaid medical bills
when their employers went bankrupt
without having paid the insurance
premiums
what a nice surprise
the big winners in bankruptcy naturally
are lawyers accountants and bankers
that's when the loots all divvied up
particularly since the 1979 revision of
the bankruptcy code
eliminated the requirement that quote a
spirit of economy prevail when
bankruptcy lawyers set their fees
as might be expected the hogs are
hunkering down to the old trough
in miami for instance a lawyer in a
bankruptcy proceeding for the gac
corporation
sought court approval for a fee
you're gonna love this
for two hundred and ten dollars an hour
for seven thousand hours of work
or a cool 1.5 million dollars for a half
a year's job
the judge settled the paltry hundred and
fifty thousand dollars on them
you know friends maybe we're all in the
wrong line of work
and with all this talk of bankruptcy and
depression i thought i was making the
shrewd move socking my money into apples
and pencils
well i have a story here on the
tragedy of dolphins around the world
particularly in japan this was provided
by the greenpeace people well in the
spring of 1980 japanese fishermen began
slaughtering dolphins off of iki island
they thought then that the dolphins were
stealing their catch
refusing to acknowledge the fact that
overfishing and heavy coastal pollution
by man
really bore much of the blame the real
blame
dolphins just by the hundreds lie
dead along the beaches of ikky island
and by japan is waiting to be processed
into fertilizer
the japanese fishermen
plan to continue this slaughter and they
will unless worldwide pressure is put on
them and this is the
what the greenpeace people are trying to
do
worldwide
thousands of dolphins are being killed
every year by americans japanese turks
peruvians
man's war against the dolphins doesn't
have any boundaries at all
the united states alone the government
allows
the killing
of 31 000 dolphins a year by american
tuna boats
so how do these
wonderful amazing
fun-loving gentle animals end
ground under fertilizer
the consequence of man's unthinking and
unfeeling relation to the earth and his
fellow creatures
let's focus on one of the current and
most spectacular
revelations that the cia has made in
recent years and that is their expose of
nicaragua that was just yesterday the
day before we're taping this where a
department of fence personnel and cia
director bobby inman
i think it was
claimed to have photographs that showed
that nicaragua was greatly increasing
their military forces that it was on the
same model as cuba's that this was all
being funded by the soviet union that
nicaragua was systematically carrying
out genocidal operations against indian
tribes living in nicaragua where they
had pictures of villages that had been
destroyed
what would your attitude towards this be
i think the first time that i can
remember since the bay of pigs
that a single
there may have been one other case but
it's almost the only case since then
that the cia or u.s intelligence has
disclosed satellite data from which they
say this came
now satellite data by its very nature
and depending on
how far they enlarge it
can be made to prove anything
these pictures i'm not saying i do not
know i have not seen the pictures but
we are asked to believe that these
picture pictures were taken within the
last several months
in nicaragua or over nicaragua by u.s
satellites we are further asked to
believe that
the the
activity which is portrayed in these
pictures
is taking place as of now
uh
recently
secretary hague
said and he held it up as as the smoking
gun in a press conference
that
his information was that the nicaraguan
government was engaged in
massive repression against the mosquito
indians right that was the big point
they made again yesterday with these
pictures of burned out villages
well one of those the picture to which
secretary hague referred to in his press
conference ten days ago
was a picture which was published in le
figaro magazine in in paris
and it later turned out that that
picture had been published with a
caption saying that this was
the nicaragua the present nicaraguan
government
showing them burning houses and burning
people alive i believe
uh it turned out that that picture
and le figaro has admitted it since then
was a picture that was taken uh during
the samosa rule and that those pictures
were five four five years old
and of course
mr hague has had to or general hague has
had to
pull back on that one but they are now
still saying that there's massive
repression against the mosquito indians
i would simply point out that
it's a dichotomy and a contradiction for
this government to
give a great deal of attention to the
human rights of mosquitoes if in fact
these abuses are taking place
when in fact native americans are not
accorded the same attention by our
government
nor are the el salvadorian people who
are systematically being killed by these
death squads and the guatemalan indians
are being almost annihilated it's almost
a genocidal campaign by the guatemalan
government against the indians in
guatemala
i do
hope that
some of this
well first of all there is a
a lot of evidence coming out that the
part of the campaign by the cia against
nicaragua isn't is through paramilitary
units and squads of
so much former soma sista soldiers who
are being trained in honduras
and their campaign is against these
mosquito indians and a lot of hundreds
of mosquitoes have been killed by those
squads and cross-border raids
one of the
reasons why
that the nicaraguan government has
been forced i believe by these campaigns
to to move a lot of these people away
from the areas where they're in danger
is because of those activities not
because of a policy of the nicaraguan
government it's as a result what would
their reason to have genocide against
these tribes the current government
nicaragua
the state department hasn't given any
hypotheses about why they would be
engaging in this i can't see any motive
for it yeah it seems strange
well they pretend and would have us
believe that the nicaraguan government
is
is a totalitarian one-party
top-down dictatorial rule and that they
have no
wish to
integrate the mosquito indians into into
their into a society into their society
and that furthermore they
have us believe that the mosquitoes want
to secede or want to have an independent
country or state or at least an area
which they can call a separate country
i don't think there's any evidence to
show that that's what the mosquito
indians wish
john since the time we did that
interview with lewis wolf there's been
quite a few revelations about cia covert
operations in nicaragua can you comment
on those i think there was some stories
in these times
about some of the things that the cia
was up to there i can comment in a
speculative way since i i don't you know
i'm analyzing the news now based on my
past experience of course
but uh
let's see what's the inflation rate
since uh
1975 to 1982. in america yeah
what would that amount to five years
it's been about 10 a year almost even
more the point is that the ci's budget
it's been announced that the the ci the
president signed an order on the first
of december ordering the ci into full
paramilitary covert action against
nicaragua from honduras
organizing mercenaries to destabilize
the countryside to counter the cuban
aggression in that country is what what
they announced was the justification
and
the budget they were given was 19
million i compare that with the 14
million that i was given in
five and i'm going in for the angolan
operation
the parallels are quite striking you
know there were parallels with the
angular operation in the bay of pigs
uh for example and other covert actions
but then guatemala was different and
iran was different so you know each one
each situation is different but here
we have so it's so close they're working
from honduras we were working from zaire
and kinshasa
they're working with
ex samosas
we were working with the portuguese
exiles the portuguese who had fled for
example
creating an army out of these people
also they have
quote mercenaries but actually soldiers
who were sent from
argentina for example and
venezuela and chile and colombia
to to join this force we had people
coming from various places from france
for example and of course the south
african force
they're functioning
i could i could map out the the office
for you the program the international
program some things that i would observe
if you've read my book is that such an
operation is global the commander would
not be sitting in honduras running the
thing the commander of the nicaraguan
task force will be in washington he will
be sending agents
all around the world coordinating
different aspects of this thing they'll
be sending cables to every station in
the world
advising the chief of station what his
activities should be these will be the
local police and the local president the
local press to create an atmosphere
supporting to the greatest extent
possible what they're doing
seeking arms that aren't attributable
seeking sources of
news comments and releases that can be
put together in white papers to
persuade and then the bottom line
that the justification reagan has given
and the ci have given for
doing this intervention is to counter
the cuban activities in nicaragua but
see the point is that they're not going
to be any cubans die in this thing
they're i believe there it said that
there are 2 000 cubans in nicaragua now
they're functioning to help build an
airport and no doubt military advising
although i've
not seen that confirmed anywhere a lot
of doctors medical personnel doctors and
medical personnel and teachers and
whatnot and from italy and several other
countries as well it's not just cubans
oh indeed
nicaragua but a variety of countries the
nicaraguan arms it's been shown are not
coming from the soviet union they're
buying them from france and italy
and all kinds of other places or are
they coming from from
from cuba this has been proven but
but
the point is that this program of the ci
is not going to be killing cubans
it's going to be killing nicaraguans
it's not going to be killing nicaraguan
officials
not that many nicaraguan soldiers it's
going to be destabilizing the
countryside blowing up bridges
ambushing bush buses
if they follow the pattern that they
have in other places there will be some
schools bombed and marketplaces bombed
to destabilize the economy so it can't
function so the network and fabric of
society will break down they kill
village leaders i've read
that the phoenix program being
duplicated killing village leaders
hauling people out and executing them to
terrorize them from
from cooperating with the government and
their families and their families in
fact
the last three weeks in these times has
had some very good articles on nicaragua
that indicates that from honduras some
hit squads were sent into nicaragua that
have killed at least 30 leaders and just
innocent people in that region and have
terrorized peasants and people living in
nicaragua near the honduras border
because of these hit raids although on
the other hand they've led these people
to organize and become even more firm
and resolute in their will to protect
their country so sometimes these
destabilization programs backfire and
end up stabilizing the country and
unifying it certainly did in the bay of
pigs the ci invasion there a unified
cuba under a fidel castro he came out of
that thing 10 times 100 times stronger
than he was going into it
and and that probably will be in effect
in nicaragua
these nicaraguans dying will be added to
the 800 000 i mentioned earlier the
the victims people who die
as a direct as direct victims of ci
covert actions in the last 30 years the
minimum figure given by all responsible
parties in press and government studies
and whatnot is eight hundred thousand
the figures range from eight hundred
thousand to a couple of million victims
of ci operations indirect type of
indirect now that does not include for
example the people who died in the
vietnam war which was a direct result of
a cia covert action more than what
million and a half in indonesia the
million and a half in indonesia
now that's that's a lot of dead people
now the circumstances of this killing
are pure terrorism
recruiting terrorists to go across the
border and blow up and assassinate and
kill
we have to remember that the next time
president reagan or alexander the hague
are making their pious statements about
the threat of international terrorism
and the horrors of international
terrorism the united states is without
any serious competition leading the
world in international terrorism
today and for the past 30 years john
isn't there something unique about this
nicaraguan situation is that the
administration is openly
admitting that they are carrying it on
that's truly a difference and this gets
back to the rogue elephant is the ci a
rogue elephant or is it has it all these
years been doing what the president
wants
and of course the truth is both in some
cases it's done what it wanted contrary
to presidential orders in other cases
it's done what the president probably
wanted but
didn't say
in this case because of the nature of
the secretary of state and the president
the cia is clearly doing exactly what
the president wanted now the president
didn't hold a press conference to say
i'm sending in the cia to kill people in
nicaragua
but
it has been admitted by the white house
that they did
it's been leaked and the president
smiled at the leaks that he did order
the ci into this action so he's clearly
you know he's he sees himself as a you
know marshall reagan uh
sort of you know showing off how he can
shoot you know let those people know
he's got got something he can do
louis while we're on central america we
might also note that your group has
published a book called white paper
white wash in which you analyze the
infamous white paper
that was published by the american
government to justify american
intervention in el salvador can you just
briefly indicate some of the obvious
whitewash in the white paper and some of
the things published in your book and
then maybe we can tell our audience
where they can get this
the white paper was published uh
in 1979 by
by uh
well i should say i'm sorry there were
prior indications of
of propaganda about u.s intervention
in el salvador but the the original
white paper that we're talking about
here came out in 1981 february february
1981 and it was
said to have been captured the series of
documents that were captured
by the salvadoran armed forces
now
we should remember first of all that
there were three accounts offered as to
how the information was captured one
said it was
found by a state department intelligence
men who went to to el salvador and saw
it on a table in the headquarters of the
salvadoran armed forces a second account
said that
it was found in what was called a safe
house of the guerrillas in san salvador
and the third and most unlikely account
was that it was
captured from a gorilla who was found
walking through the streets of el
salvador with a whole packet of
documents under his arm
each of those accounts were offered as
the source of of these documents
we have analyzed uh the documents that's
in in this book uh
co-co-edited by uh warner pulcha or
edited by warner protel with interviews
with philip agee
and
it's very interesting to analyze as has
been done in the book
line by line word by word the
the so-called white paper
there are parts of the paper for example
that refer to in english
sections of the so-called
spanish original spanish language
documents that don't exist
uh there are creative translation
exactly there are there's one document
for example that's
partly in spanish in handwritten spanish
and then
on the same document it's typewritten in
english
so we're asked to believe that whomever
was sitting down at the table writing
these shopping lists for arms from cuba
from vietnam from ethiopia
where and libya
was going to move from a pen in in
spanish to a typewriter and type in
english and very i might say very
literal very literary english
there are a lot of contradictions in the
white paper basically we should
understand this because it was and is
the
the first and and the most important
justification that has been used by the
government for its intervention in el
salvador
of course now they
pretend that because the white paper was
so widely discredited
even by one of its authors who gave an
interview to the wall street journal and
disclosed that
he even had a lot of questions about it
um so i think there's a lot of reason
that this document or this exercise in
propaganda is a classic in cia
propaganda
if the audience wants to order this book
how can they get it
well they can write to the publisher
which is deep cover publications
should i give the address in post office
box 677
new york new york
10013 and it's uh
well 650 plus a dollar fifty handling
yeah and can people also get the mailing
list for your other publications you've
published a book called dirty work the
cia in western europe and another one
called dirty work the cia in africa
as well as putting out this covert
action information bulletin will you
give information and how they can order
that uh those other they can write to us
to covert action information bullets in
in washington i'll give the address uh
post office box
50272-50272 washington dc 2
004. and we'll be happy to send you the
information
i find this very sad by the way i find
it troubles me
not
obviously because i was once part of all
this but also
just as an american citizen to realize
that this country is indulging
in activities that are just as cruel
and just as as depraved in some cases
and almost as extensive as what for
example the
the gestapo indulged in in germany
we haven't liquidated
5 million jews
but 800 000 minimum figure people killed
in terrorist circumstances in the third
world is a lot of people dead
and the responsibility ultimately yes
the you know it's done by the cia and
it's a secret organization and therefore
we have plausible denial to our own
consciences because there's nothing we
can do about it we don't know about it
they didn't consult us but the other
side of that coin is that the ci is the
united states
police organ and what it does we the
american people are responsible for so
that in addition
to the personal losses of freedom of
speech and freedom of the press
we are responsible for the genocide of
terrorism that's taking place against
the world today in our name and with our
tax dollars and with the changes of the
laws and
executive orders
the whole apparatus of the intelligence
services including the fbi and their
right-wing hit squad buddies like the
nazis and the klan
are now being able to be turned on the
american people turned on the americans
with impunity remember that lou wolf
mentioning the executive order which
we've all followed with great interest
that too is president reagan going
public bragging about what he's doing
with the cia but don't forget that the
ci has always functioned extensively
inside the united states mh chaos you
know a billion dollar program was all
domestic
and experim mk ultra experimentation on
american citizens with drugs and lsd and
whatnot that went on for 20 years and
that was inside the united states on
american guinea pigs the opening of mail
for 20 years was american citizens mail
they've always done this thing the
operation mongoose
war against cuba was run from from
florida and they had over a thousand
safe houses and boat docks and whatnot
that they were operating from the united
states the training
facilities
for
torture for interrogation techniques
were in san antonio texas at one time
a few years back and you know that's
something that's easy to move somewhere
else i don't know where it is today
john recently one of the individuals in
the cia that was in charge of these
covert operations has recently resigned
and that is admiral bobby inman who was
allegedly second in command at the cia
it's been widely reported that inman
himself believed that william casey who
is the director of the cia was overly
fond of quote adventurous but
ill-advised cia operations aboard abroad
and senator joseph biden of delaware has
recently noted without inman the
intelligence agencies may be given
license to try all kinds of questionable
things here and abroad in the light of
what they've been doing even under inman
already what would you your comments on
the inman resignation in the future of
the cia
well i would have to regret the fact
that he left not that he was a paragon
of liberal virtue but he seemed to be
when compared with
william casey and and some of the others
jesse helms over on the senate side
carlucci his predecessor he seemed to
have some pretty strong instincts for
protecting american institutions
he protested the names of agents bill at
one time or at least one version of it
as being unessential to american
national security and of course he got a
lot of criticism for that
it would seem that he was in
effect a moderating influence on some of
the cruel or instincts of
men like casey who of course is a
a very inept and corrupt individual the
corruption being that he's maintained
his own business portfolio he's a
millionaire while he's ci director he's
running the cia he's running his own
businesses and of course from the cia he
can have some influence on world
economic matters
he has also been appearing at republican
fundraisers and of course that's one of
the biggest no no's
in
in
the united states governmental system to
have the head
of a police organization with the
influence of the cia to openly advocate
one political party's position and help
it raise money
in that kind of a of a corrupt
adventuresome
atmosphere
one would have to regret inman's
resignation the whole milieu the
environment is favorable to reagan and
the ci and what they want to accomplish
what they are accomplishing
if you go one step further
and consider
reagan's policies his first year in
office he's muted this a little bit
faced with a clear
indication by the american
people populous about war
he and and attila the hague were
speaking
constantly about the viability of
nuclear war
war was an effective tool we shouldn't
be afraid of war
going to war in el salvador discussing
sending troops into nicaragua talking
frequently about going to the source
quote in cuba
and
talking about you know demonstration
wars or limited wars nuclear wars in
europe and whatnot these people gave
every indication that they were looking
for war
now
they have toned this down a little bit
in the last two months
first you saw the turn we all saw the
turn everybody reads the newspapers
when the polls
responded 89 percent of the american
people said they were did not favor
american
military intervention in nicaragua
and this was a pretty clear indication
to the the president that the american
people were not going to support him he
would not be a successful president if
he got us into a war it would be
something that he would have trouble
selling trouble maintaining at the same
time there was a move in congress that
if the government of el salvador didn't
modify its human rights positions they
wouldn't get more money for aid
and then the second thing of course has
been this massive groundswell reaction
to his attitudes towards the bomb
and
that's
national every corner of the nation
little bitty towns across the nation
organizing effectively and having big
demonstrations
as well as the big the big
cities
the nation and the world so deeply
concerned about the threat of nuclear
war
and just absolutely horrified that you
could possibly have a president in
office
whose mental capacities were so limited
that he would actually talk publicly of
demonstration atom bombs in europe
popping off a bomb to show our will and
resolve
limiting nuclear war to europe and the
possibility of surviving nuclear war in
the united states this has horrified
people to the point where he's got a big
political problem on his hand from the
famous ground zero and the freeze
and the result is that it's it's forcing
a change in their stated policies and
attitudes they're toning down
quite a bit from what they were saying a
year ago at this time for example
responding to the mood of the nation
and some frustration i think clearly
well thank you john that's fine we've
exhausted you again but we appreciate it
now news stories from three different
years first may of 1982 we started our
three-part investigation of cia covert
action with a program with john
stockwell and lewis wolf that talked
about the intelligence identities
protection act and they did a criticism
of it of how it would subvert american
civil liberties freedom of speech and
our democracy well since then we found
out in an article in the progressive
that uncle walter walder cronkite has
joined john stockwell and others in
criticizing the intelligence identities
protection act the progressive reports
that walder was talking in dallas to the
national associations of broadcasters
convention and he attacked the reagan
administration's pattern of restriction
on press freedom he deplored
administration support for supreme court
rulings that permit police to raid
newsrooms in search of sources and the
compel journalists to disclose sources
in court he also lamented the
administration decision to limit the
freedom of information act and the
reagan policy of no longer declassifying
government documents automatically after
30 years walter scorned a plan to
protect business information that would
keep investigative stories and
commentary on topics ranging from
pollution threats to dangerous drugs at
a serious disadvantage and he called the
free press's democracy the only
fail-safe system against both the
dangers of its own excesses and the
approach of tyranny while i'm citing
story from the progressive i might also
note that in the page after the story on
walter cronkite there's a story dateline
austin texas with a headline and that's
the way it really is
the article begins the ever shriveling
scope the triumph of technique over
content and the cheerful rush to
incipity among anchors on network news
are familiar aspects of television news
from the happy talk and video gimmicks
of local newscasts to the corporate
paranoia of the networks television's
current events reporting has become
almost dysfunctional viewers know this
hence the deep-seated distrust of the
broadcast media but the oligarchic
nature of the television industry has
blocked alternatives up until now
leaving most americans relying on the
lighted box as their primary source of
information at last the stranglehold may
be broken the article reads and by whom
and by what we cried for the past three
years we learned a weekly news
documentary program alternative use
produced in austin the broadcast over
the public access channel provided by
the local cable franchise has been doing
what others do not it has been
presenting very unslick intense
hour-long documentaries and interviews
with the likes of ramsay clark russell
means stokely carmichael madeline murray
o'hare john henry faulk george wald john
henry falk helen caldecott william
kunsler daniel ellsberg and john
stockwell and then the article goes on
to describe our program the format and
what we're trying to accomplish so we
thank the progressive for publishing
this and we'll pat ourselves in the back
well i mean i'm slick hey i thought we
were pretty slick
trust us
well i'm i would assume by now that
you've heard about that famous remark by
thomas k jones deputy under secretary of
defense for nuclear theater
uh forces or strategic theater nuclear
forces that's part of our own slickness
there he says hey don't worry about
nuclear war everybody's going to make it
if you got enough dirt
if there are enough shovels to go around
you need those two things dig a hole
covered up
with a couple of doors throw three feet
of dirt on top and you're safe from a
nuclear holocaust folks
well
even to top that in that was just plain
stupid but in insensibility the
department of energy study recommended
that after a nuclear attack
people over 40 years of age should be
the first to leave their bomb shelters
hail with that
these post-tac pioneers would search for
food and clean up a bit you know for the
younger survivors because they say older
people have a shorter life expectancy
anyway
and the study reasoned that near lethal
doses of radiation would make much
difference anyway by the time they
caught anything they'd already be dead
and also they wouldn't pass on any
radiation-induced genetic defects to
future genera well i don't know
anyway they asked gray panther president
maggie [ __ ] what she thought about that
she told them i'm right behind you frank
yeah 39
but something is being done about it
the
city council in cambridge massachusetts
determined that they instead of having a
cooperation day for evacuation with the
civil defense folks they would have a
preventive evacuation day
by urging their citizens to join the
mass rally for disarmament in new york
city on june the 12th
a lot of people are going to that
do y'all like fairy tales
well there's a dandy one every week in
sunday's parade magazine if you're into
real fantasy
i'm talking of course about your basic
free enterprise message from the ever
loving people of mobile oil
part of their multi-million dollar a
year pr package
i'm sure you've all seen this is called
observations and they've always got this
little cartoon in here that's never
funny in case you've all noticed before
well this whole thing is designed to
show america once and for all who are
the good guys and who are the bad
a biggest beautiful campaign you might
say
we're seeing a lot of this kind of thing
on tv now too
the white water canoeist experiencing
the thrill of victory while
simultaneously clearing the good name of
getty oil
those cute little oil wells to swarm
with 59 different endangered species of
birds and bugs
the industrious cartoon pie maker who
has the world beating a path to his door
to bid on his pies
they all strained to make that one
meaningful statement
hell we just plain old folk like you
well is anybody listening
personally i'm underwhelmed at their
sincerity
and the tad put off by the political
motif of stuff like this
you think reagan's a supply cider this
column makes them sound like karl marx
or freddy ingles
this particular one was exemplary
it made a monumental leap of reasoning
across two centuries to assert that
george washington's troops almost
starved to death at valley forge because
of price controls we'll all be i didn't
know that
after a quick razzle dazzle with oil
production figures and constant 1980
dollars the text then leads you to the
inescapable conclusion that it would be
silly to put price controls on natural
gas
i mean we wouldn't want the troops to
starve
all those poor old oil barons down
gutting it out in the trenches with the
dirt the vermin the spilled perrier
i may just be paranoid but
whenever corporations start billing
their programs and ideas as a boon to
all mankind
i think it's time to hide the silverware
and i still can't help but feel a little
bit guilty when we fund the torture of
peasants so that united fruit can bring
the world to us packed in a light syrup
from may of 1982 we now switch to may of
1983.
according to the wall street journal mr
reagan's energy department has been
busily doling out more of that welfare
for the rich
rich oil companies in this case
the general accounting office which is a
congressional watchdog agency says that
the department is making settlements
with oil moguls that are unduly
favorable to the industry
so what's new
the gao charges that the reagan team is
letting some of the major oil companies
off the hook to the tune of tens of
millions of dollars
shell oil u.s steel's marathon oil
mobile oil company and several others
were nailed for over charging customers
prior to the decontrol of oil in 1981.
you may have seen the 60-minute segment
that dealt with how new oil miraculously
became old oil with its higher price tag
and all that rot
well now comes payback time and suddenly
the reagan gang is getting generous
again with our money the
administration's top official in the
department rayburn hanslick says the new
settlements are based on quote more
accurate and more realistic cost figures
than they ever had before
i guess somebody boogered up a neater
set of books for the department this
time
shell oil for one will save a pretty
penny because of this
company officials had originally
bargained with the carter administration
to settle an alleged 151 million dollars
in overcharges
the carter people said annie up 75
million will call it square
well now mr reagan's department says
that 50 million is quite enough thank
you
marathon oil overcharged customers some
41 million dollars according to
government investigators
mr hanslick and the boys in the back
room will settle for
11 million
the topper is a deal they cut with
mobile
overall mobile may have ripped off
buyers for more than 900 million dollars
900 million dollars in various cost
violations
our benevolent energy department says 29
million will cover it
or cover it up might be a better way to
put it
because of the hubbubs surrounding these
sweet deals the department has delayed
signing some of the agreements and
others pending with gulf oil and cities
service
which was just recently swallowed up by
accidental petroleum
the wall street noted also that the
reagan team has not shown any great
enthusiasm at all for pursuing this type
of enforcement
in fact the administration budget for
1984 proposed cutting their allotment
from 21 million down to 7 million they
don't want them nosing around too much
but why would they want to bite the hand
that feeds them
for my own part i'm not particularly
surprised by this whole affair
once a week it seems the business press
carries something or other like this
it's blatant stuff and it's pretty old
hat
what really amazes me is that so much
energy is devoted to railing against
piss ant things such as unreported
busboy and waitress tips
social security overpayments where
gramps has gotten a part-time job
selling candles
in food stamp abuse
these damn people are eating
and all the while it's business as usual
in the county house
you know i've just about decided to
become a finance baron so i can live
outside of the law too
say craig i found an old
statistic which
used about a few years ago but it bears
on what you were saying a while ago when
the price of gasoline at the pump is
raised one penny
around the country
do you know how much
wealth goes from us to them
yeah it's got to be astounding more than
five dollars
it's
2.9 million dollars a day a day a day in
pennies so you can imagine how much is
going back to the oil companies after
the oil brought the price down and then
the
government uh
put on that what five cents
against five cents but they raised it
much higher
it's about 17 anywhere between 10 and 17
cents they raise it above that so you
can figure out that
additional above the tax
and figure out from 2.9 million a day
take that over a year i'm no good at
math but that's a lot of money
in may of 1983 the congress went along
with reagan's crazed plan to
produce the mx missile and it looks like
money is being freed to continue the mx
missile program even though it appeared
that it was going to be defeated however
there's an article in these times that
indicate that it's going to be a little
bit difficult to base these mx missiles
anywhere in the country because of the
public opposition to the missile the
grass roots opposition that's arising
when carter was talking about his race
track concept to have the mx missiles on
this race track that would be put in
nevada or utah the citizens of that
state organized and put tremendous
pressure on the governor the state
legislature to try to make it not be the
case that these missiles be put in
in nevada and utah so that suddenly this
program was abandoned by the federal
government
then they started talking about montana
and wyoming as a good place to put the
dense pack mx missiles well there was a
lot of opposition that has already
arisen in montana the governor came out
against it and eight of the nine
congressional representatives as well as
grassroots groups throughout montana
however wyoming the governor and some of
the congress people there seems to be a
little friendlier to the mx and they
have invited the air force to come and
check out the state and said they would
cooperate with them as an mx missile
site however a grassroots opposition
group in wyoming is now starting to form
called western solidarity some of the
same people that organized opposition to
the mx in these other states are going
to
wyoming to help them organize they're
planning a big rally in cheyenne wyoming
and more and more groups and individuals
are becoming aware of the dangers to
their ecology and of course to their
very survival if there was ever a
nuclear war
so grassroots opposition to the mx
missile program is growing significantly
in wyoming itself therefore if the
reagan administration attempts to try to
base
these mx missiles anywhere in the
southwest to the northwest they're going
to get grassroots opposition from a new
group called western solidarity that's
organized throughout this region
consisting of ranchers of church groups
and environmentalists of public citizens
all of whom are opposed to the mx
missile including now a group in wyoming
we've had stories from 1982 and 83 and
now
may 1985.
probably ronald reagan's greatest
political and public relations blunder
was his visit to bitburg germany
to the cemetery where
ss troopers were buried along with other
german and american soldiers you also
might wonder why reagan originally
didn't agree to go to a concentration
camp and to a commemoration service for
the dead jews who were killed in the
holocaust
well the new york times reported that
nancy reagan put a zap on that that she
thought that holocaust and concentration
camps were sort of a downer and too
depressing and she thought that reagan
should project a more positive happy
cheerful image so she vetoed a trip to a
concentration camp however there was
such an outcry when it was revealed that
there were all these ss stormtroopers
buried at bitburg that reagan did
finally agree to go to a concentration
camp well the village voice the week
before reagan's visit to germany had an
article about anti-semitism in the
reagan administration and some very
dubious attitudes of some of his
officials in an article called bitburg
tip of the iceberg
reagan's communications director is pat
buchanan who you may have seen
on the cable news network on the firing
line show and buchanan i think was also
a spiro agnew speechwriter and very
active in the nixon administration craig
you've read about buchanan's attitude
towards anti-semitism in the jews that's
right there is an office in the congress
had a hand in setting up
under the aegis of the justice
departments called the office of special
investigations
and which supposedly was set up to
prosecute and deport alleged nazi war
criminal criminals and collaborators who
fraudulently entered the united states
well mr buchanan since he became
involved with it has not been
too gung-ho about prosecuting these
people in fact he said in a speech he
said he saw nothing singular about the
holocaust he said and it quote just
seems to me that allocating funds into
running down aggressively these people
is just not a proper use of resources
like you say he was involved with the
the nixon campaign he was a speechwriter
for mr nixon
and if you'll recall if you read the the
watergate tapes the book
that was made from the tapes
there were several anti-semitic slurs on
the tape from mr buchanan and it said
that
mr buchanan was the one
important white house staffer who
convinced mr reagan to to go ahead and
visit bitburg
the reagan administration in fact ronald
reagan himself this time is also in
trouble for writing a friendly letter to
one of the most notorious
anti-semitics in the whole united states
a doctor roger pearson who's the
president of a council for social and
economic studies reagan wrote him a
letter congratulating him on his journal
and saying that you are performing a
valuable service and bringing to a wide
audience the work of leading scholars
who are supportive of a free enterprise
economy a firm and consistent foreign
policy and a strong national defense
however mr pearson has also been active
in anti-semitic circles for many decades
in britain in 1956 he started
publishing a racist journal called
northern world whose purpose was to make
whites aware of their forgotten racial
heritage and to cut through the judaic
fog of lies about our origin and the
accomplishment of our race and western
culture in 1958 mr pearson founded a
northern league in britain whose purpose
was to bring together the strands of
post-war neo-nazism and whose members
included racial theorists were active in
the nazi regime in germany then he came
to the united states in 1964
and began publishing a journal called
western dent
destiny who had on its editorial board
what the village voice described as a
rogues gallery of racist and
anti-semites clan leaders holocaust
debunkers former waffen ss officers
british and american neo-nazis and
fascists members of the white citizens
council etc
they then started publishing a journal
called mankind quarterly that
specialized in racist articles including
one
that reported on a 1962 trip to south
africa that was sponsored by the
apartheid government to study quote
bantu racial characteristics that was
illustrated by a photo of a zulu man in
profile intended to illustrate his
jewish nose
since then mr pearson has published a
whole stream of racist and anti-semitic
books eugenics and race blood groups and
race he received 36 thousand dollars
from the pioneer fund that was dedicated
to scientific racism and run by
political associates of senator jesse
helms and more recently has been
involved with
the liberty lobby
anti-semitic and racist in publishing
several anti-semitic things so this is a
gentleman that ronald reagan sent a
personal letter to congratulating him on
the valuable service that his public
publishing enterprises are carrying
forth and
even after the criticism was leveled
against mr pearson for being one of the
most grotesque racists in his country
the reagan administration refused to
retract the praise in this letter and
refused to criticize mr pearson publicly
showing an incredible moral blindness on
the part of the reagan administration
towards the issue of anti-semitism it's
nothing new though
and that's alternative views for this
evening we hope you enjoyed our
three-part series on covert action
around the world
if you have any comments to make
here's our address
alternative information network
p o box 7279
austin texas
78712
good night